on suit la framboise bonsoir alors vous
vous avez votre invitation
ça me fait plaisir merci à vous d'être
avec nous vous êtes en estrie dans la
région sociosanitaire de l'estrie parce
que tuteur de découpage au québec la met
donc l'estrie est fermé depuis la mi
novembre à peu près parce que c'est
devenu une zone rouge vous dans votre
cas ça vous touche bien sûr quelle est
votre situation
les apartés en dong gook pierre et moi
c'est non quelle est votre situation
présentement sur les framboises alors
lis pas en zone rouge
tout est fermé dans nos services
à l'exception des soins personnels qui
est qu la massothérapie et une
esthétique
ouais et ça veut dire quoi pour vous
d'être fermé présentement sur votre
chiffre d'affaires sur vos affaires mais
en fait la massothérapie et les soins
normale représente peut-être 1 40% du
chiffre d'affaires
cependant notre notre industrie nos
modèles d'affaires représentant du tout
et c'est la beauté de la lamal gamme de
ses services la restauration et bien sûr
la thermothérapie qui est qui et la
majorité nos immobilisations le tous
ensemble une magie qui fait en sorte que
la baisse des ses plus grosses alors en
temps de pandémie lorsque on ajuste les
soins mais plutôt que d'être à 40% du
chiffre d'affaires normalement pour les
soins peut être content bas à 15
peut-être avaient-ils indices pour
certains nous on a de grande clientèle
qui vient de montréal
alors les gens vivront pas de montréal a
mis son découragées de le faire deux ils
viendront pas un excursions pour venir
nous visiter les secours en soins et
quand on parle de chiffres de chiffre
d'affaires au spa balnéa ça veut dire
quoi
mais en fait je peux vous donner une
tranche assez large
reprises fait entre 5 et 10 millions
chiffre d'affaires ok si on parle de
l'industrie des sports au québec
l'association québécoise des sports
représente peut-être 65 membres
précision et de support représentant de
la cus
non mais à ma lecture on doit sûrement
atteint 2 200 millions de chiffre
d'affaires
est-ce que l'or en ce moment est ce que
le soutien offert par québec est
approprié pour votre entreprise pour
votre type d'entreprise je dirais qu'il
te fais mal adapté pourquoi très très
difficile à obtenir comme vous l'avez
dit en introduction un groupe pour nous
d'obtenir l'argent du provincial ou un
support viendrait vie à investissement
québec sous forme de congés de capital
ou de deux subventions conversion d'un
remboursement à la fin d'un créer ou en
cours de pré après un moratoire c'est
compliqué on est on est en temps de
crise
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait nous comme
gestionnaire comme propriétaire on gère
une crise on n'a pas le temps de
commencer à monter des plans financiers
démontré des pertes en fait il faut
réussir à montrer à investissement
québec où un autre prêteur con con et
qu'on était en manque de liquidités pour
passer la crise
ouais et souvent des liquidités la faire
c'est justement ce que pour certains la
plupart d'entre nous on est des
gestionnaires sage on a un bas de laine
et ce bas de laine là bas il est en
train de passer dans la crise alors je
ne suis pas éligibles au programme
d'investissement québec ou du provincial
alors pour nous un gros le seul argent
qu'on use provinciale c'est la
majoration de 12.5 pourçain que le
provincial a donné sur le loyer sur six
mois trente huit mille dards 38 mille
dollars et vous évaluez avoir perdu
vous prévoyez avoir perdu qu'on vient
sur votre exercice budgétaire
bientôt l'exercice disons qu'on l'amande
parce que ça va être facile de le faire
de mars à février et des gens' on se
fait dire 500 confirmation se veut dire
dans les communications à elle qu'on
serait fermée jusqu'au 11 janvier on
attend on aimerait sans avoir une
précision à cet effet mais pour notre
établissement
je suis pas gêné de dire que ne perdra
que voir avoisiner le million de dollars
alors que les autres ont fait de dollars
de pertes
et là vous vous évaluez le soutien que
vous avez eu ou que vous aurez à 38
milles mais vous initiale du provincial
exactement parce que vous avez aussi la
subvention fédérale
la subvention salariale subventions
servent à leurs salariés un sous bois en
subventions sur le loyer dans son
ancienne forme de belfort hockey en
terminant vous demandez quoi à partir de
maintenant qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
écouter le provincial je sais pas en
termes de taxes qu'on paie peut-être
qu'on envoie 6 m $ sur 10 au provincial
pourquoi le provincial éponge pour le
reste de la perte
on parle pas de compenser pour les
profits non non on gagne et on parle de
puiser une perte comme citoyen
corporatif toutes les industries qui
sont fermées en ce moment font bien plus
que leur part alors nous on demande ce
qu'on demande c'est à dire pour
continuer à aider des employés n'est pas
juste des entrepreneurs en secteur fermé
qui paient la dap tous les employés
surtout mon gestionnaire qui passe à 80
à 60 % de leur salaire
ces familles la paix plus que leur part
de note a2 de l'effort de guerre si vous
voulez convaincre dans lequel on est
alors une égalité soit yens pour les
règles qu'on doit suivre mais il n'y a
pas d'égalité citoyens du tout sur les
citoyens corporatifs qui peut cette note
là voilà instruisent pas pardon vous
alliez en terminant je dis je disais que
j'allais dire que l'industrie lisent pas
et est définitivement une industrie
solide
three prometteuses ont fait partie de la
solution
on est des centres de santé descente et
mieux-être évidemment physique et
mentale
ce n'est pas un loisir parfaite je dois
garder fermées je dois vous arrêter le
message est clair il est passé merci
beaucoup monsieur la framboise merci
bien